[Music]
honey I love you we may have watched
this Disney star live on the sweet life
for years but off screen it wasn't
always smooth sailing for debby ryan the
27 year old actress basically grew up on
two huge Disney shows however while fans
of the star watched her bring the
positivity and light-hearted characters
Bailey and Jessi to life it was actually
just a facade stuck in the clutches of
the controlling network the pressures of
being a Disney star were just too much
for debbie who dealt with everything
from severe anxiety to vicious feuds
with fellow cast mates so what exactly
happened to Debbie behind the scenes of
some of our favorite shows and more that
I read the more inspired I became to
follow my dreams
despite basically being the poster girl
for confidence during her time on the
Disney Channel
Debbie's road to fame wasn't an easy one
growing up in Texas she didn't want any
spotlight shined on her suffering from a
speech impediment
debbie has admitted she was often shy
and dealt with a lot of self-confidence
issues but luckily with the help of her
aunt she was able to correct her speech
and it was then that she found her love
for acting I got into acting when I was
like nine years old I moved to Germany
and I wanted a place where there were
other Americans spoke English in Madrid
a theater her mom who was a drama
teacher introduced her to what would
become her favorite place the stage
Debbie opened up the Teen Vogue about
her acting beginnings explaining that it
was the freest she felt
just hiding in plain sight it wasn't
long after that that her mother realized
that for her daughter acting was more
than just a childhood hobby and Debbie
soon began landing small roles in
commercials like her fellow Disney stars
Demi Lovato and Selena Gomez Debbie
scored her first TV show gig on the
popular TV show Barney and Friends in
2007 little did she know that just a few
months later she would be starring on
one of Disney's biggest series The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody was and still is
an iconic staple for Disney so landing a
main role on the spin-off series the
suite life on deck was nothing
of life changing for Debbie during an
interview with clever TV she called her
experience playing bailey pickett insane
and couldn't believe just how much her
life had changed since filming for the
series began in the early months of 2008
Bayley soon became even more central to
the story when her southern accent and
quick wit captured the heart of one half
of the twin duo we were finally gonna
see the majestic ancient redwoods as her
storyline with Cody also known as Cole
Sprouse began to gain traction
Debbie soon became one of the leading
ladies on the Disney Channel she was
even given her very own movie Sixteen
wishes and just a year later her very
own Disney show Jessie make sure he
doesn't steal anything however no matter
how much Debbie loved portraying the
fun-loving nanny that seemed to have all
the patience in the world she knew there
was more to the film industry than just
the cost of phobic walls of being a
Disney star Jessie is a little sarcastic
and also aspirational she's a little
dark and funny she told Teen Vogue but
she's a 28-minute version of a story
wearing things work out in the end
which is not real life and in Debbie's
reality being a star on Disney wasn't
all picture-perfect like the lives of
her characters I think I made the mouth
too bit while the actress was thriving
when it came to landing roles on the
family-friendly Network expanding her
resume outside of her roles on Disney
was almost impossible when she was
offered roles it was all filtered
through Disney executives that set out
guidelines for any role she had during
her time on Jessie Debbie guest-starred
on the medical drama private practice
and in 2013 opened up to the Chicago
Tribune about how complicated the
process was of course they set
boundaries
she said about Disney I have to be fully
clothed that sort of thing Debbie was
forced to keep her picture-perfect
g-rated image even at the expense of
expanding her career outside of Disney
being a team is hard but growing up in
the spotlight with millions of people as
your critic is even harder and when it
happened in the wake of so much
horrifying tragedy and so much being
unearthed debbie has revealed how that
added pressure left her with anxiety and
eating disorders during her years on
Jessie she later opened up about being
constantly compared to previous Disney
stars and the constant fear of slipping
up in the public eye filled her mental
illness you may be shocked to find out
that
Debbie was also involved in an abusive
relationship during her time on the
network and it's how all with People
magazine she explained that while
filming she was part of a friendship
that took a turn I was in a friendship
kind of a working relationship and it
ended becoming more and more destructive
and getting emotionally and mentally
abusive and I think before we get to
that wait there are a lot of warning
signs of mental abuse emotional abuse
thankfully she put an end to the
relationship before things escalated to
a dangerous level in 2015
her contract with Jesse eventually came
to an end with the show reaching 100
episodes and four seasons marking it as
one of the longest-running Disney shows
ever
however the drama from her time on the
set of Jessie seemed to follow her even
outside the disney gates sky Jackson
also known as the adorable and spunky
Zuri from Jessie reportedly accused
Debbie of bullying her at a young age
and recounted their time on set together
as being in a constant feud a tumblr
count reached out to Debbie letting her
know that Skye had created a second
Twitter account where Debbie was being
threatened with receipts of her past
actions Skye's been telling me and
others you push and bully her she made a
second Twitter which is full of hate
towards you and even has her own fans
hating on you even mentioning that
Debbie was involved with illegal
substances Debbie made sure to set the
record straight on the online Feud
responding to the user by saying I knew
that the cast were gonna grow into
double digits and then become preteens
and teenagers by the end and that's a
rough age especially in this industry
reminiscing about the happy memory she
had on set with the younger cast she
realizes that bitterness is not fixable
by rollercoasters and treats and that's
a truly sad fact it's no surprise that
after leaving Disney Debbie took some
time to herself in order to regroup and
to also sort out what direction she
wanted her career to go in it was a
conscious choice for me to duck away and
not do a lot of public facing things
while I created a body of work after
Jesse that I was really proud of she
told Teen Vogue she was also afraid to
have the public shaming on former kid
stars being projected on her telling w
magazine as I grew and began to find
myself I just did so with discretion
taking baby steps in the end seemed like
the right path for Debbie considering
her life post Disney was anything but
picture-perfect just a year after the
series had
did the actress was arrested for
impaired driving although she was no
longer attached to Disney the star made
sure to address her role as an
inspiration to a younger crowd in a
Twitter apology over the last few days I
have had the chance to think about my
actions and I wish I had used better
judgment I recognize that I am a role
model and I've always worked hard to set
a good example for my millions of fans
there are over 8 million people in New
York
her career seemed to be at a standstill
as well according to Debbie a lot of
casting agents just couldn't get past
the metaphorical Disney trademark that
seemed to follow her she told Rolling
Stone she was forced to bang down some
doors that were closed because people
saw me with Mouse ears she's also
admitted to also loving that she has
more freedom now when it comes to the
roles she chooses to play play teens and
young adults and you know I think it's
we're kind of in this suspended timeless
world sometimes she thinks over time on
g-rated TV as being stuck in a timeless
cycle but outside of Disney she's able
to explore the depths of different
characters the actress finally found
some solid ground when she was cast in
the Netflix series insatiable where she
starred alongside 90 star Alyssa Milano
the dark comedy followed teen patti
Bledel who after being bullied for years
because of her weight suffered from an
eating disorder while also seeking
revenge on her haters in the form of
winning a beauty pageant say the truth
will set you free
there's no freedom while the show
received plenty of backlash for its
portrayal of mental illness Debbie told
Teen Vogue that they knew this
conversation needed to be had and that
the social brokenness also needed to be
discussed in the series despite the
controversy the 2018 show still ran on
the streaming service for two seasons
insatiable seemed to be the tipping
point for the celeb and now in 2020
she's thriving and better than ever not
only has she learned to cope with her
mental illness with coping mechanisms
like intentional breathing but her
former toxic relationship has been
replaced with her loving marriage to
twenty one pilots band member josh dunn
who she describes as her best friend
we're both public-facing people and i
think it's really important for us to
maintain the intimacy of anybody there's
a lot in our lives
Debbie's even looking back at her past
with a smile on her face she's been
joining in on the internet trend but in
both hilarious memes of summer for more
awkward scenes
just this past April she tweeted I was
serious about my craft from a young age
and studied technique alongside Roxanne
from a goofy movie fans in the comments
absolutely loved it
Debbie also seemed to have found a
healthy outlet to reminisce about her
time as a child star she hopped on the
trend and started her very own podcast
called there you are with debbie ryan
debbie yourself reason that this was the
perfect way to explore experiences in
her life that she hasn't got to talk
about yet this feels like a really great
place for me to sit down with some
incredible smart and interesting people
that i've met through my work and have
those meaningful conversations with them
career-wise Disney's leading lady has
been working on getting more roles on
the big screen and even has two movies
the opening act and 19th both in
production I think any sort of
transition is is difficult but I think
it's more just about intentionality
growing up with the spotlight constantly
on her couldn't have been the easiest
venture for Debbie especially while
being a part of a company that enforced
strict rules when it came to her
personal life but besides the few
setbacks she had earlier on in her
career
Debbie seems to be on the right track
with a whole list of opportunities in
the industry tagging along what do you
think about Debbie's behind the scenes
life have you checked out some of her
more mature projects since their time on
Disney let us know what you think in the
comments section below be sure to hit
that subscribe button and ring that
notification bell to stay up to date on
everything the things